Let's continue looking at our DB helper.
The other important function
that we are required to fill in
is the on-upgrade method.
This function gets called when the
database has already been created but
the version is changed.
A version change or upgrade should
signify that the columns, tables or
general structure
the database has changed.
The SQLite Open Helper knows
the database version has changed because
the version we passed into
its constructure has changed.
Make sure to always change
the database version
when you make changes
to the database tables.
You might think,
why would I care about this?
I'm not upgrading anything yet,
so why bother?
Because it's important to make sure
that your application won't have
errors when you make changes
to the database tables.
Since we are going to be using our
database as a cache for web data, and
not for use generated content,
we'll drop the tables,
which deletes all of the data.
If the data had contained information
that was user generated, of course,
we'd want to preserve it.
To do that, we'd likely use
alter table to add new columns.
See the instructor notes for
more information on alter table if you
are interested in how this is done.